so the irony is that zielinski ran on a
peace platform right he was he was going
to bring peace to Ukraine and he was
going to join everybody together again
he was good he was a uniter and then my
theory of what happened was that the
reason why he did the exact opposite but
he's banned all opposition media he's
banned opposition political all that
stuff he's done horrible stuff he's he's
become the worst kind of dictator but
why would he do that I think it was
because NATO he knows that if he goes
against NATO that they will kill him and
so will the right wing in his country
which are the Asaf Battalion Nazis uh
those people love it I mean you've I
watch videos of these guys talking about
how they love fighting and killing and
that these guys are the real deal Nazis
and they're you know I'm not saying that
their majority of people in Ukraine are
Nazis I'm saying a big controlling
factor of their military and their
politics are right-wing Nazis and that's
what's going on over there and people
don't know it's